rihanna is showing off her growing baby
bump i couldn't tell you how happy i am
that's the singer who's expecting her
first child with rapper asap rocky
looking fabulous as always rocking an
oversized jersey and matching gloves but
all eyes are on ree's best accessory her
belly she captions the sweet pick how
the gang pulled up to black history
month she may never wear it but she save
it so our babies will be flyer than
their parents no doubt rihanna and asap
are excited to become parents a source
tells e.t the couple who announced their
pregnancy on monday is so happy
rihanna has always wanted to be a mother
and have children she thinks asap is
going to be the best dad it's amazing
and i'm honestly truly blessed real you
know and so far the rapper is proving
her right our source says that asap is
tending to all of the grammy winners
pregnancy needs
[Music]
the source adds quote they are really
enjoying this moment together as a
couple rihanna and asap have such a
strong bond and they can't wait to
experience parenthood together
[Music]
and you can say riri becoming a mom is
fate during a chat with ellen in 2012
the fashion mogul manifested having a
family someday do you want kids
yes eventually i mean absolutely
would you do it alone or do you want to
wait till you're
in a relationship or married i mean i
would prefer
to have a you know a full family
um i'm sure pretty sure i couldn't
handle it if i had to
um on my own but you know that's not
what i'm striving for and get this in
2008 rihanna knew exactly what she
wanted her life to look like quote in 10
years i want to have already started my
family and have some businesses of my
own a fashion line a makeup line and i
still want to be doing what i'm doing at
a much bigger capacity by the grace of
god fenty beauty check fenty skin check
savage by fenty check baby on the way
check overall safe to say ree has
manifested her dreams it's turning out
great so far so good it's all of these
little tiny things that you just do for
fun that in the moment
they just make you feel great as for the
dad to be he saw fatherhood in the cards
for him too last may he not only told gq
that rihanna's the love of his life but
he also said one day he'll be an amazing
dad and have a very fly child like
anybody else you just take it in stride
you know keep going congrats to the
couple on their greatest achievement yet
[Music]